[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BARRON: Welcome, everyone.
Great to see.
Welcome to Evan--
EVAN DAVIS: Thank you.
Nice to be here.
PETER BARRON: --who obviously
most of you will know--
BBC Newsnight presenter,
top economist, and author.
And I must say, after
the last couple of days
that we've been
doing this, this is
a bit of an oasis, a
blessed relief where
we can get away from antitrust
and talk about bullshit.
Excellent, so Evan's
book, "Post-Truth--
Why We Have Reached
Peak Bullshit and What
We Can Do About It."
Now, it's something
of a crowded market.
I've seen something like--
EVAN DAVIS: Three came
out on the same day.
PETER BARRON: --at
least three books
that came out on the
same day on this subject.
EVAN DAVIS: There was a
bit of bunching, I think.
Because if you're aware
the others are coming out,
then you all start trying
to come out on the same day,
but it's a popular topic--
Oxford dictionary's
word of the year.
I actually, slightly
differently to the other two,
had started work on this
one, God knows how long ago,
just because I observed so
much bullshit in my day job.
And actually in
economics, there's a--
economists study bullshit.
I mean, there's a whole field
of information economics.
And economists basically
work on the assumption
that if you, Peter,
said something
to me that you would say,
regardless of whether it was
true or not, if you
would say that anyway,
I would be mad to believe you.
So I wouldn't believe you.
And so you wouldn't
bother saying it.
I mean, that is basically what
economists call an equilibrium.
I won't believe you if
you'd say it anyway.
You won't say it because you
won't waste your breath on it.
And there will be no bullshit
in the world of economic theory.
And this has earned people
Nobel Prizes, that insight.
And then we observed there
is quite a lot of bullshit.
So I actually started out--
before "Post-Truth"
and the other books.
I started out thinking,
why is there so much of it
if the theory says
there shouldn't be any?
PETER BARRON: And
then you had to rush
to get it finished, did you?
As--
EVAN DAVIS: Well, then, it
had been sort of moving--
progressing a little slowly,
and Tim, the very excellent
publisher, then said,
Evan, this is the time
to publish a book on bullshit.
And you've got to finish it,
and we've got to get it out.
So that was, yeah, it was.
PETER BARRON: So I
was kind of expecting
a book about fake
news, and there's
a bit of a fake news in
it, but it's primarily not
about fake news.
It's about the sort of
bullshit in society as a whole.
EVAN DAVIS: Right.
So it has application
to fake news,
but essentially, it started out
and remains primarily a book
that is trying to explain
why in politics, business,
and journalism, people are often
not entirely straightforward.
And why it is believable
when they're not
entirely straightforward, why we
fall or why that works to not--
so you're trying
to explain that.
When you get into that, that
sort of the general theory
of bullshit bit, when
you get into that,
you see that everything
that happened in 2016--
and Brexit and Trump, and indeed
in the last election, Corbyn
and May, the way that played
out and other things too--
you see that the theory kind
of explains or has something
to do with quite a lot of
the new political divide
between populism and liberalism.
And that political schism can
be explained in terms of some--
I mean, just to give
you a very quick peek.
I think one of the reasons why
Trumps and Farages have been
very popular is because the
traditional politicians,
their communication
repertoire, has run out.
Their bullshit has faded,
basically, and become
rather tiresome to many voters.
And a Trump comes
along-- and you know,
you can say whatever
you like about Trump,
but that guy can kind of
communicate in many respects.
PETER BARRON: So
you're kind of saying
it doesn't have to be true
to reveal a wider truth.
EVAN DAVIS: OK, when we
look at why there's so much
bullshit, one of
the reasons is, is
that a lot of stuff
that looks like bullshit
is deeply informative.
And it's not about the truth
value of the proposition,
it's about the
underlying message.
And so Trump came along--
I'll stick with Trump because
it's a bit further removed
from our country.
Trump came along and spoke
what most people regarded
as bullshit.
So he would say, unemployment
in the US isn't 5%,
it's 40%, which
is simply untrue.
And even a mild modicum of
knowledge on the subject
would tell you it's not true,
and even just anecdotally,
it's not true.
It's not 40%.
But when he says that, he's
trying to communicate something
a little bit deeper, which is
not about is it true or not.
He's trying to say,
I'm on the side
of the American worker
who feels picked on
and doesn't have
security in that job.
And I worry about blue
collar America rather than
LGBT rights, which is what
Hillary Clinton is banging on
about.
So all the time,
Trump's bullshit
was designed to signal
something about Trump.
And in fact in the book, I talk
about him and Wrestlemania.
If you've seen the YouTube
videos of Donald Trump,
his participation in World
Wrestling Entertainment
and Battle of the Billionaires.
And this goes back a bit
before he was a politician.
Now, in a funny sort
of way, you might
say that the bit where he
body slams Vince McMahon,
and they fall to the ground and
scrap each other, I don't know,
but I'm suspecting there was
a bit of theater or stagecraft
to that encounter.
But again, you could
call it bullshit,
but also you could call
it quite informative.
I don't think Hillary Clinton
could have done that, you know.
So you learn
something about Trump
from his willingness
to play that game.
So by your bullshit, I
learned something about you.
PETER BARRON: In the
beginning of the book,
you talk quite a bit about--
you sort of define bullshit
and different kinds
of bullshit and so on.
You make the point that
there's a cost to lying.
People don't want
to be called a liar.
EVAN DAVIS: No.
PETER BARRON: But
it's quite clear
that some of the things
that Trump is saying
are demonstrably not true.
So how does he kind of
gotten away with and not
felt the cost of lying?
EVAN DAVIS: Yeah,
so the first point
is that actual direct lies,
for complicated reasons
I've never quite
managed to work out,
direct lies carry a
disproportionate penalty
relative to simply
misleading people
by being selective
with the facts,
or being economical
with the truth,
or carefully positioning words
that in the Bill Clinton,
"I didn't have sexual relations
with that woman" kind of way
were designed to mislead
while not actually lying.
I think he probably slightly--
PETER BARRON: Actually, apology,
but go into a little bit
more detail on that because
it was pretty extraordinary,
the dancing around and the
meaning of words on that.
EVAN DAVIS: But your
question was, why did--
how has Trump got away
with saying stuff--
PETER BARRON: Or
are you declining
to talk about Clinton and his
sexual relations, are you?
EVAN DAVIS: Oh no, I
will talk about it.
I'll come back to
that, but I want
to answer your first
question, which
is I don't know how Trump has
got away with it, actually.
I don't know.
I think if he had done it--
if he did it in court or
he did it in a solemn way.
And I think the other thing
is I think Trump supporters,
they understand Trump.
The quote of the election
campaign, almost a cliche now,
is the press took him
literally but not seriously,
and the supporters took him
seriously but not literally.
And so you kind of know
what you get with Trump.
You know, he stood up at that
press conference and said,
I have the biggest
electoral college vote
of any president since Reagan.
And then the CNN
guy got up and said,
well actually, Obama got
a bigger one than you.
And he says, well, I
meant a Republican.
And he says, and
George Bush the second
got a bigger one than you.
And says, well, I
was told different.
I was told different.
I didn't know.
Is that right?
But I had a great big
victory, didn't I?
Do you agree I
had a big victory?
And so he's so blase
and you kind of--
you would never really--
you would never really kind of
act on a sort of a Trumpism,
would you?
You sort of know you have
to check the facts after.
So I think in a way,
it's because he's
so blase with facts that
he gets away with it.
Because no one is
any way misled.
That's it.
Clinton--
PETER BARRON: Clinton.
EVAN DAVIS: Well
so, Clinton is just
a great example of bullshit and
the distinction between lying
and bullshit.
I mean, bullshit is a
whole lot of things,
but Clinton's was "I didn't
have sexual relations
with that woman."
The people who had
interviewed him about this
had defined sexual relations.
I can't remember what the
formal definition was,
but it was contact between any
genital part and another part,
blah, blah, blah.
And so they defined
it because they
knew Clinton might wriggle out.
PETER BARRON: But he--
this is not really
safe for work, is it?
But he kind of
argued that she was
having sexual
relations with him,
but he wasn't having
sexual relations with her.
EVAN DAVIS.
But he didn't have relations.
PETER BARRON: Strict definition.
EVAN DAVIS: By the strict,
literal definition of the words
that they had--
and he said, well, I just
went by your definition,
and I did wonder, you
know, as though he was just
doing his best to be helpful.
But I mean, we know he wasn't.
But bullshit comes in a lot
of other forms though, Peter.
I mean because I
think you've got
that, which is very carefully
attuned to the facts.
Clinton knew what the facts
were and was carefully dancing
around them.
You've got a spin, which is
what you do all the time, which
is kind of trying--
you're never going to lie,
but you're going to interpret
the facts in a generous way
to yourself.
And then you've got
a whole lot of sort
of afactual forms of bullshit,
which is it's just not about
whether it's true or not.
It's just about
attention-grabbing
or it's about gibberish.
I quoted wine review in there.
I mean literally, I
googled "wine review."
The first thing that came
up was a wine review,
and I just read it.
And it was just such gibberish.
I thought that is a
fantastic example.
It's It's not that
it's true or false--
and even itself it has
a purpose, you know.
She obviously knows about
wine, but could she really
detect those seven flavors?
I mean, I don't
believe she could
detect all of those
[? simultaneously ?]
and say they were
in sync, and it's
a juicy wine with a personality,
a structured personality.
Do we really think wine--
PETER BARRON: Yeah, but it was
trying to tell you something.
And then you mentioned
the advertising.
So largely, advertising
is bullshit,
and you don't believe the things
that happen in advertising,
but they are
nevertheless sending you
an important message.
EVAN DAVIS: Right, so
all this comes back
to a lot of the time,
the bullshit you observe
has an underlying message.
And yeah, so that wine
review is telling you--
A, she liked the wine.
It was quite a long
way of saying that.
B, it was a pleasure to read.
And C, it told you
she knew about wine
because she knew
what words to throw
into the gibberish
of a wine review.
But advertising is a
very interesting one
because economists have had
a bit to say about this.
So if someone says,
buy my product,
it's the best
product in the world,
you'd be foolish really to
believe them because they'd
probably say that anyway.
If they spend 20 million pounds
telling you, buy my product,
it's the best
product in the world,
should you believe them now?
At one level, you shouldn't
because 20 million pounds
makes no difference to the
likelihood that they want you
to believe what they're saying.
However, if they spend
20 million pounds
telling you to
buy their product,
it tells you something
about how much belief
they have in their product
because they wouldn't spend
20 million pounds
on this if they
thought it was
just fly by night,
here today, gone tomorrow.
And so they're spending
20 million pounds
because they think
this product is good.
And they may not
even understand that,
and you may not understand why
you respond to advertising.
But there's a sort of an
underlying message there
that is carried by the
lavishness of the ad that says,
this is a product
we're investing in.
And that's an important message.
And if that means hiring
Catherine Zeta-Jones
to advertise your mobile
phone service, that
is better than hiring another
beautiful woman to market
your mobile phone
service because the fact
that you've hired
Catherine Zeta-Jones says,
we really like this product.
We're here and investing in it.
And it's important as a
consumer that you know
that they like their product.
So a lot of
advertising, I think,
can be explained that way.
PETER BARRON: Let's
talk a little bit
about the recent
election campaign.
So it's a pretty extraordinary,
historically extraordinary
campaign, and you saw
Theresa May not doing well
by very much sticking
to soundbites, and then
Jeremy Corbyn apparently
being extremely authentic.
So where was the bullshit there?
EVAN DAVIS: Well, in some
ways you could write up
the UK election campaign as
similar to the US one, that you
had an outside politician who
had commanded a style that
was just more authentic,
less media savvy,
more kind of saying
what he thinks
against a traditional
politician with the controlled
messaging of traditional
political communication
industry.
And in the kind of battle
of communication styles--
each, by the way, has
their own bullshit in them
and each has their own kind of--
their own style and their
own artifice and their own
promises.
Some may or may not be
sustainable or deliverable,
but they each have
their own elements
of kind of fantasy about them.
And in the battle
of those styles,
the old style political
bullshit was defeated.
She won the election, but no one
would say she won the campaign.
And personally, I think
that was the last time
that kind of
controlled messaging
can be deployed on anything like
that scale and expect to win.
It's just worn out.
And These things
will come and go.
There will be a period
of the new style outsider
authenticity, and I'm sure
that will grow wearisome.
And people will move
on to something else.
But I definitely think
the spin and control
that one would say started
with new labor post '92,
it kind of peaked and
it started diminishing.
And Theresa May's campaign was
the sort of last, last one.
PETER BARRON: You talked
about peak bullshit.
Where did peak bullshit happen?
Did it happen in the Brexit
vote or the Trump election?
Does Corbyn
represent the falling
of the line in
terms of bullshit?
Would you be able
to talk about that?
EVAN DAVIS: Yes, so I was
thinking of peak bullshits
back in 2013.
And then 2016 came
along, and you
realize that these peaks
are like climbing hills.
There's always another one just
beyond when you get to the top.
No, I mean, I think
we're in an era--
this is one of the key
points of the book.
I think we're in an era in
which politics is divided,
societies are feeling
discombobulated
by change, cultural change,
cultural and economic change.
There's a discontent
around, and truth has come--
for this period of
our politics has
come to matter a bit less
than it sometimes does.
So in the election
campaign, there
was less scrutiny
in this campaign
about whether the plans
added up or were sensible
or made were affordable.
There was less of that.
The campaign was more viscerally
about whose side are you on.
Insiders, outsiders, liberals,
populists, globalists,
or nationalists, these
divides have taken over.
And with those divides
being very fearsomely
felt, a lot of people,
when a proposition pops out
of public discourse
to hit them--
we send 350 million
a week to the EU--
people are not
thinking, is this true?
Does it matter if it's true?
What is the evidence?
Who says this?
What interests do they
have in saying it.
People are not appraising
it in that way.
They're looking
at it and saying,
does my team believe this?
Is this what my side is?
And belief in propositions,
for the moment in our divided
times, is more about
a kind of tribal
belonging than about
evidence appraisal.
And so yes, I think we are at
a high in terms of bullshit.
And I think we're at a
high in terms of people
being willing to swallow
stuff, or like it on Facebook
and share it and regurgitate it
because our critical faculties
have been overcome by
our tribal allegiances.
And I don't know about you.
I see it with my
friends on Facebook,
who by and large are
kind of more metropolitan
than the typical bunch.
And I just see
them liking stuff,
not because they've
thought about it
or that because
they're open-minded,
but because it makes
them feel good.
So it's gratifying
to like something
which your friend
likes and which
is affirming him all in this
kind of common involvement.
PETER BARRON: Yeah, and
what we saw after Brexit,
in particular, is people are
horrified by the Brexit vote
so they shouted louder about why
our voters have voted that way.
Counterproductive you would say.
EVAN DAVIS: Well you see, I
think if you believe all that--
I think that one of the--
how to respond to
this phase we're in--
I mean, look, bullshit's
always been with us
so I don't want to exaggerate
the point that we're
in an era of bullshit.
But I do think we are in an
era of somewhat more of it
in public discourse.
And if you want to deal with
that, I mean, some people will
say, well, you need arbiters.
You need the Advertising
Standards Authority
to monitor advertising.
And you need the
Statistics Authority
to monitor statistics.
And you need a bit of that.
I'm not against
that, but I think
it's less about arbiters of
what is true and what is false.
It's much more
about getting people
to put evidence and
truth and reliability,
back up their priority list.
And to make people
worry more about truth,
you need for them to worry
less about their tribe's status
and their tribe's position.
And if you are a
bunch of Brexiteers--
unlikely-- and I was
a remainer, and I
was trying to persuade
you you're wrong,
shouting that you're a
bunch of dimwit idiots
who didn't know
what you were doing,
and you are gulled
by 350 million,
and don't you understand what
the economists have been saying
about how bad it will be, that
it is not going to persuade you
any more than trying to
have an argument about facts
with a 9/11 conspiracy
theorist will persuade them.
It won't persuade them.
So the way to persuade
you is to reduce
your sense of tribal
allegiance to your side.
And the way to reduce your
sense of tribal allegiance
is to offer you more respect,
to listen harder, and have
a more gentle
conversation, and not
just to shout at you about
the facts and the proof
that you're wrong because that
really entrenches positions.
Any of you have dogs
that sometimes you
tug the dog on the lead to
get it to come your way,
and sometimes that
makes the dogs want
to go that way even more.
And I think there's
been a lot of that,
particularly on
the remainer side
of shouting at the Brexiteers.
It's shouting about
how stupid they are,
and I don't think that's a very
good way of persuading people
that they're wrong and
probably counterproductive.
PETER BARRON: And
that kind of feeds
into your philosophy
of interviewing.
And obviously, people
make the contrast
between you and Jeremy Paxman.
And you saw the Jeremy Paxman
style in the election debate.
Your attitude is to draw people
and draw things out of people
rather than be combative.
EVAN DAVIS: Yeah,
I mean, I don't
think there's a right or
wrong interviewing style.
And one or two newspapers
always try to set it up
as me against Paxman style.
And I mean, Paxman is a god,
a giant among interviewers.
And I'm a pigmy compared to
him, so that's not his at all.
I think that there has
been a problem of everybody
trying to be a Paxman,
which has had the effect--
if you get too many
Paxmans, it has the effect
and has had the effect of
training our political class,
in particular to kind of
obfuscate rather didn't say
anything.
So it sort of
works up to a point
and then you just train the
politician to be boring.
And the conversation
just ends up
in a kind of [? an old ?] school
draw and them basically just
scrapping on the floor.
So I think there are--
we do need other interview
styles to be available.
Paxman and Humphrys,
absolutely the best
at that sort of
adversarial approach.
I've certainly thought you
need to notch the dial away
from that.
It's not that I've taken a
particularly intellectual
approach, thinking it through.
It's more I just am incapable
of doing what Paxman does.
I'm just too empathetic.
But I think there is a
danger to not being a Paxman,
which is there is a risk of
it just being a bit boring.
And the absolute
worst risk of it is--
I mean, at the very least,
if the politician closes up
and Paxman is
haranguing them, you
can enjoy watching
Paxman haranguing them.
So at least half the
conversation is interesting.
If the politician doesn't
open up and are still boring,
and if I'm nice to them,
and they're still boring,
then you just end up with a very
boring conversation because you
haven't even got me being funny
and pulling faces at them.
And it's just not as
entertaining as Paxman
getting nothing
out of them if I'm
getting nothing out of them.
So there is a definite
problem, but I don't
know what you do about it.
I think you just have to
keep exploring things.
You have to be a little
bit unpredictable.
And you have to hope that
people will occasionally
be a bit more revealing
in an interview
if you're giving them a
little bit more rope, really.
And sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't.
But as they say,
there's no right style,
no right or wrong style.
PETER BARRON: Now I
was quite surprised
that in the index
of the book, there's
no mention of either
Google or Facebook,
which I was kind of expecting.
And you don't cover
hugely fake news,
but in terms of peak
fake news, do you
think we have reached
peak fake news?
And actually, I wonder, as
the emphasis has been placed
on the fake news
in recent months,
is it in proportion to the scale
of the problem in this country?
EVAN DAVIS: Well, I've got
a slightly odd perspective
on this.
To be honest, I think
probably some of the talk
is a bit overdone.
The reason I think it's
overdone is that people--
I think ultimately, the
most important thing
is that the truth is out there.
And that it is fairly easy to
navigate your way to the truth.
And if people are not navigating
their way to the truth,
they're believing stupid
lies despite easily available
evidence to the contrary.
I tend not to think, well,
that's Google to blame
or we need a big censor to
come down and block the lies.
I tend to think
we need to ask why
are people believing nonsense
when truth is available?
So that's my sort of take.
So the first thing I
think you guys have to ask
is, is the truth available?
And if you are autodirecting
me towards nonsense,
I think that's a bit
irritating because I
think you don't want
people to be autodirected
to nonsense because that's
making the truth less available
rather than more available.
So your first question has
to be is the truth available
and is it easy to
navigate your way to it?
And that's where I think
your responsibility-- that's
where I would tend to
say, I don't feel strongly
about any of this,
actually, but I
would tend to think that's
your responsibility.
If people choose not to
navigate their way to the truth
because they would
rather believe
in fairies or in the Holocaust
conspiracy theories or 9/11
conspiracy theories,
if they'd rather
believe that kind
of nonsense, I think
that's the bigger problem
that's above your paygrade.
PETER BARRON: But you
wouldn't intervene
to stop people claiming--
EVAN DAVIS: Right.
I would intervene on
certain things, Peter.
I think I don't want
it to be easily--
I don't want pictures
of child abuse
to be available and searchable.
I don't want
bombmaking techniques
to be to be easily available.
So I think there are areas where
you're going to close it down,
basically.
But I think those are
pretty few and far between.
My own-- my sort of instinctive
view is that it's much more
important that the truth is
available and easily available
and is your kind
of navigable and--
easily navigable to
those who want it.
In a funny sort of
way, if there are
people believing batshit
crazy stuff about 9/11,
or someone who
doesn't believe that,
I want to know that there are
some people who believe that.
I mean, that's the useful
thing for me to know.
There's a fine balance
between oversuppressing it
and undersuppressing it.
I have, and the book is,
optimistic about human nature.
Most people, most of the
time in the long-term,
gravitate towards
things that are true
rather than that are false.
So I feel optimistic that,
by and large, the truth
does emerge.
And so I'm less--
I suppose just instinctively
a bit less keen
on trying to control the
public discourse away from sort
of stupid, stupid things.
I worry more about--
the only other
thing I've said, I
do think kids should
be taught at school
what the difference
between a reliable
and an unreliable source is.
And so I think a little bit of
critical thinking is good news,
and you can help with that.
PETER BARRON: Great.
OK, let's go to some
questions from the audience.
There's a microphone
there in the middle,
if anyone would like
to queue up for it.
EVAN DAVIS: And do
ask about anything.
I mean, you can complain
about the BBC all day.
I'm here available
till five to 2:00.
So that's normally what
happens anyway, but--
AUDIENCE: Hello?
Hello?
Yes.
Thank you for joining us today.
My question is
journalism has largely
operated with the principle
that facts are facts,
and you have to report them.
In an era of post-truth
where a person can get
elected president,
ignoring largely the facts,
How can you
journalists hold them
accountable within
that new framework?
EVAN DAVIS: Right.
OK.
So two things, good question.
How do we hold people who are
fast and loose with facts, how
do we hold them accountable?
Just number one, don't overstate
the importance of facts.
I mean, there are facts.
And I'm not a kind of,
you know, relativist
who thinks nothing is
actually objectively true.
There are facts.
But the vast bulk of our
disagreements in society
are not so much about the facts.
They're about the weight
we put on different facts.
And so the Brexit
debate, the 350 million
was a contested fact,
and it was not true.
But the reality was
it was 280 million.
And 280 million, 350 million,
I think to most people,
it still feels like
a lot of money.
And so I don't think the
difference between 350 and 280
explains the outcome.
So look, I just think
don't over-obsess on facts.
Most of it is about
judgments, and the judgments
in that referendum
was the economists
say it will be bad to leave.
Or the vast bulk of them say
it would be bad to leave.
But it's not a
fact that it would
be bad to leave the EU, bad for
the economy, it's a judgment.
And people are entitled
to say we hate economists.
We don't trust them.
The first thing is it's not
about facts most of the time.
Sometimes, but not most.
Secondly, how do we
hold people to account
when they are lying
about the facts,
fast and loose with the facts?
I think we just
present the facts
in a gentle and uncritical way.
They've said it was 350 million.
It's actually 280 million.
That's all you have to do.
If people don't want
to listen, then you
need to ask why will people
choose to believe the lie
rather than believe the truth,
and that's a different problem.
So all we can do is
gently and as patiently
and objectively as
possible present the facts
as we understand them.
Now, there is one
complication which
I want to give you
with the 350 million
fact which is very unusual, that
there's a sort of a fact which
is at such--
call it, you know, the
center of such a dispute.
The one thing I think the
media has difficulty with,
and this proved, is that
when a campaign throws out
a lie knowing it's
a lie in order
to get us to report it's a
lie in order to draw attention
to it and give weight to
their side of the argument,
I don't know what we do.
PETER BARRON: And you
think they did that?
EVAN DAVIS: Well, there were
some formulations where they
were kind of more accurate,
and there were some where they
clearly weren't.
And Dominic Cummings, who
ran the lead campaign,
has I think use the
phrase "designed
to promote discussion,"
or something like that.
And I think if
you're in a campaign,
and you know the argument could
be about business and jobs,
could be about the money
we send to Brussels,
or could be about
immigration, you
might want it to be about the
money we send to Brussels.
How on earth do you get
it to be on that terrain?
Well, maybe the way you get
it to be on that terrain
is to throw out a lie.
And then we'll spend the
next week arguing about
is it 350, 280, or 150?
And then we've kind of
done their job for them.
In the act of debunking
what they say,
we've done the job for them.
And I think that's something
we need to think about.
I think that's a
sort of tricky one,
because normal rules
would be we have to report
what the campaigns say.
If one campaign lies, we have to
say by the way, it's not true.
We're not impartial
between lies and truth.
We can say that's not true.
We should report it's not
true, but we can end up
giving it undue prominence.
PETER BARRON: And we now
have the American newspapers
policy's on reporting
Trump tweets, for example.
[? Theo ?]
AUDIENCE: Is political
journalism failing in Britain?
And just to give you some--
how I think about
this, the election,
we saw this traditional way
of reporting politics, which
I subscribe to the "Today
program, Newsnight, the kind
of reasonable and respectful.
And then you have this
kind of nontraditional--
online [? VRS ?]
[? Media, ?] you know,
all of these kind of news sites,
Paul Mason kind of launching
diatribes, the idea that
the institutions that do
the reporting are in
themselves inherently biased.
And when you look at the side
that I am sympathetic to,
the traditional, respectful
media, in 2015, it
told us that there would
be a hung parliament,
and it was an outright majority.
Then this time, they told
us that there would be--
PETER BARRON: An
outright majority,
and there was a hung parliament.
AUDIENCE: And then when you
look at the kind of the people
that I think are the nutters
online, they were right.
And now, which one is nonsense
and which one is the truth?
EVAN DAVIS: Well,
I think-- you know,
I think one of the things--
and this is really important,
is you mustn't think that there
is some objective fount
of knowledge which
is known to somebody.
Or we just have to
find the person who
has that fount of knowledge.
And if we can just
find the right person,
then everything will be clear.
It's just not like that.
Public discourse is
a discovery process.
But it's a discovery
process in which
the thing you're discovering
is moving all the time.
And so rather than
thinking, oh, is there
some systemic flaw in
the mainstream media,
I would tend to say, crap,
we get it wrong quite a lot,
don't we?
And this was one of those
ones, and the last one
was, because the rules seem
to have changed quite a bit.
It's not, by the way,
just the mainstream media.
I mean, mainstream media
didn't just make it up.
They looked at the local
election results, which
were entirely in
accord with everything
the mainstream media was
saying throughout the election
campaign.
It wasn't evidence free what
the mainstream media said.
So yes, I mean, the
outsiders did much better
than everybody said they would.
Rather than thinking you
know, what rubbish messengers,
you just think, well,
something big is going on.
Something big is
going on, and the kind
of tools which we've had
aren't working very well.
Uniform swing models
of seat projections,
which were the thing
that was driving
a lot of these projections.
Rubbish.
They just didn't work this time.
And so my view is that it's
a mess, but life is a mess.
And we're going to reflect
that messiness sometimes.
And I like the fact that you can
read The Canary, or Breitbart,
and take different
views on these things.
I like the fact that
they're sniping at us.
Personally, I
wouldn't recommend you
go to The Canary or
Breitbart for an effort
to see the other
side of the argument.
I think we will make
some efforts to present
both sides of an argument,
I don't think they will.
I think they will not do
that as well as we do.
We don't always do
it well, but we'll
make an effort to present
both sides of an argument.
So I just want there to
be a mixed ecosystem.
I want there to be people
shouting at the sidelines.
I want there to be
people who are offensive,
and people who are funny,
and people who exaggerate.
And people who give vent
to frustration and anger.
And I want there to be
kind of the New York Times
and the BBCs of
the world who will
make some effort in
their own flawed way,
to sort of be fair to everybody.
And I don't want the BBC
to be a monopoly of that.
I want there to be Sky
News, and ITV News,
and others who are making
a kind of a similar effort
to just sort of be fair
and to be measured.
And I want everybody
to know what they
get when they buy those things.
I want people who
know when they go
to "The Canary" or
"Breitbart," that they're
getting something that
is probably skewed
from a particular perspective.
And I hope that they won't think
that is the ultimate truth.
And I hope they will come
to other areas of the media
to see the other
side of an argument.
But it's a mess, and
we are not perfect.
There isn't some innate truth,
it's a process of discovery.
And as soon as you think about
it as a process of discovery,
you kind of stop looking
for the fount of all wisdom.
And then so these
people are rubbish.
They got it wrong twice.
I mean, we get it
wrong all the time.
But we're discovering it's
along with the rest of you.
PETER BARRON: Is
the BBC's center
of gravity in the right
place, would you say?
You often get attacked
from both sides.
EVAN DAVIS: We get
attacked from both sides.
I mean, look, I think it is
sort of in the right place.
I think we nudge towards
the opinions of experts
away from mass opinion,
to some extent.
And I think it's
appropriate for us to do so,
but I think the main
thing about the BBC
is its heart is in
the right place.
Most people at the BBC,
whatever their views,
will understand
that we have to be
fair to both sides
of an argument.
That doesn't mean we have
to say, on the one hand,
the Earth is flat; on the
other hand, it's round.
But we do have to sort of
be fair to the evidence
that each side puts up.
To me, it'll be terrible,
both for personal reasons,
because I'll lose my job, and
for society, if the BBC is
kind of deemed to be unfit.
Because I think
you do want people
who see their job as
being fair to both sides,
as you also want people who
don't see their job as being
fair, who see their job as
being unfair to the other side.
I like adversarial
journalism, but I
don't want it to be the
only kind of journalism.
So no, I don't think in
answer to your question,
that traditional political
reporting is dead.
I think it's been a particularly
fascinating time in which we've
got a lot wrong.
And that is life's
experience, and that's fine.
I mean, we just need to keep
working with getting it right.
PETER BARRON: Next question?
AUDIENCE: All right,
thanks for coming.
So how much do you think
the rise of bullshit
is due to basically
the lack of good ideas
or lack of solutions from
a policy point of view?
So politicians have to
increase bullshit because they
can differentiate themselves.
I mean, the two
parties is the UK
have basically become
very centralized
as they were in the '70s.
And on the business
side of things,
so in areas where they
don't have innovation,
you see a lot of bullshit.
Used to work for Unilever, a
difficult place to innovate.
And if you compare Apple,
when the iPhone came out,
they didn't say anything.
They just had an iPhone
and Google with search.
So how much do you think it's--
AUDIENCE: That's such
an interesting question.
That's a really,
really good question.
And so at some big level, my
sort of stock answer to that
would be--
I think a lot of what
we're talking about
comes back to the
financial crash of 2008.
The crash has given us a decade
of stagnation and no rising
incomes.
And that stagnation has given
us a period in which bullshit
has held a bit more sway.
When everybody is
getting richer,
and everybody's feeling we were
on a trajectory of improvement,
there's less to
sort of fight over.
And it's less
tribalistic, incidentally.
And I worry less about
my relative's status,
because we're all
getting better.
When the going gets
tough and there's
no general increase
in living standards,
it feels much more like
a sort of visceral fight
for relative status.
And then I'm going
to become tribal.
I'm going to believe the crap
that my side believes and--
just because my
side believes it.
And so I think in that
sense, your point is right.
Now, the other-- but you
take the question further,
it's a really good example.
When the iPhone comes out,
they don't need bullshit,
because it just sells itself.
And as the improvements get
much more and more incremental,
the bullshit notches up a dial
to try and pretend otherwise.
I mean, that's the
sort of grand--
I hadn't even thought
of that, but I
think it's a really
interesting theory.
I would slightly disagree with
your premise, because to me,
it doesn't feel
like at the moment
we are in an era
of low innovation.
I mean, you would
know more of this
than I do, but it still
feels to me like--
AUDIENCE: Policy points of view.
EVAN DAVIS: Policy point of view
AUDIENCE: Government not in.
EVAN DAVIS: Yeah,
good government's
not knowing what to do.
Possibly.
I mean, there's definitely
the center ground
in politics hasn't had a
good period since 2008 when
they haven't really had an idea,
they haven't had a response.
You know, the
populous right has had
a response, a sort of
nationalist response
to the crash.
The populist left has
always had a response
and said the crash
would always happen.
So they've been to
that extent vindicated
and I think feel
empowered by it.
And the kind of Blairite
middle of the road
have struggled, because
they haven't really
had a response to the crash.
And Macron is the
best kind of example
of someone coming up with
perhaps having one in France.
But we don't really know whether
he's going to deliver or not.
And you're right.
I mean, maybe that has led to
some of the bullshit we see.
So do you remember the Labour
leadership contest where Corbyn
won?
So this is September 2015.
It was definitely the case that
if you were a casual observer,
you would say the
only one who had
anything to say out of the four
standing was Jeremy Corbyn.
And the others were
kind of flanneling,
because they didn't have
enough kind of substance
to articulate a new vision.
So in comes Corbyn
with that vision.
And I do think that is a
problem for the center ground
in politics at the moment.
They're a bit bereft
of stuff to say.
And that's why at the moment
the choice is really not one
in which the center
is very strong.
It feels-- you know, Theresa
May and Jeremy Corbyn
is kind of-- there's a
missing piece in the middle.
Tim Farron, I suppose.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER BARRON: By the
way, quite close on time.
So should we take three
quick questions and then
Evan can wrap them up.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very
much for coming in.
I found it absolutely
fascinating,
especially the sort of
idea around persuasion
not being necessarily
about being right,
but about sort of reducing
barriers between tribes,
I guess.
And as a fact-wielding Ramona,
I can see how that sort
of applies to both
political parties,
but also at an
individual level--
EVAN DAVIS: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --having
arguments with people.
And I wondered if you have any
sort of good examples of that,
maybe recently, or at a personal
level that you could share?
EVAN DAVIS: Quick
answer, no, I don't.
But I do know-- on
a personal level,
I do know that every argument
I ever have is helped
and your case is strengthened
when you show enormous respect
to the other person.
It's incredible.
I mean, it's incredible how
obvious that is when you do it
and how few people
seem to understand it.
And I'm trying to
work out what's
really motivating,
which is normally
something about status.
You know, it's like the
sort of family argument
where you have an argument
about where the kettle goes
or something, and then, this
is really about your mother,
isn't it?
If you can get to that
without hostility, you do--
it is much better.
Yeah, I've got builders
in at the moment,
and I'm tempted to have an
argument with them every day.
And I do think it works better
when I'm really nice to them.
Except occasionally,
you have to get cross
to show it really matters to
you, but better to be nice.
PETER BARRON: Kitty?
AUDIENCE: Hi, just really quick,
and thanks again for coming in.
Very interesting.
As well as enjoying
bullshit and responding
to that at the moment, we also
seem to be really celebrating
losers.
So thinking about
Nicola Sturgeon
after the Scottish
referendum, and Jeremy Corbyn
fever, Glastonbury,
which is obviously
a certain type of bubble.
But why do we love a
loser post the election?
Why aren't we doing
that before the election
and shaping the result?
EVAN DAVIS: I
think it's actually
just trajectory matters much
more than you're suggesting.
So although Jeremy Corbyn
won, his trajectory was up.
So it felt like
he was the winner,
and Theresa May's
trajectory was down,
so she felt like the loser.
And momentum matters
enormously, because human beings
are sort of evolved
to always extrapolate
the current trajectory.
So in our minds, the fact that
he did better than expected
is a kind of a winning pitch.
And it has been
difficult sometimes
not to say he won the election,
even though he obviously lost
the election to Theresa May.
And so I think it's
about trajectory, that,
rather than loving news.
There are people
who love underdogs,
but it didn't really sort of
work for the lib dems, did it?
Or even UKIP, who were
a long way behind.
So, in fact, bandwagon
effects, we like winners.
We like winners.
Actually, the thing that
all parties want to do
is to pretend they're winning.
So they all lie and say, oh, our
private polling says we're on--
we're on to a thing here.
We're the winners.
You know, join the bandwagon.
You don't want to be left out.
You know what I'm saying.
So it's-- I probably don't
agree with your premise,
but it's a good question.
PETER BARRON: [? Lajer? ?]
Last question.
Last one.
AUDIENCE: I'm on the PR
team, so my question's
a little bit selfish.
When it comes to Google,
we're faced with a lot
of bullshit externally.
And it seems like we have done
pretty much everything you've
suggested.
So we've been nice.
We've been respectful
in different situations.
So my selfish question
to you is how can Google
withstand and maybe even
ride the tide of bullshit?
EVAN DAVIS: Right.
So I think it's
carry on as you are.
It would've been
much worse if you
hadn't been nice, respectful,
and all those things, so that's
one.
And secondly, just
to hold in your head,
this was something that was
said to me by Warren Buffett.
I interviewed him
for the BBC, he's
one of the best
interviews I've ever had.
It was in his
office in Nebraska.
He let us wander around with
a camera just filming stuff
while he was in his office.
He didn't have any PR in tow,
he didn't require any questions
in advance.
He didn't set a time limit.
He was absolutely wonderful.
And he gave fairly frank
answers to the questions.
And I said to him
afterwards, why don't you
have a PR when probably a mid
manager in a large company
would come with two PRs
to an interview like that?
And he said, well,
by the time you die,
you'll have the
reputation you deserve.
And so really, there's
no point in thinking
about the PR too hard.
Just behave as you will,
and I'm afraid I really
do believe that.
And so there's a lag.
There's a lag.
But if you are nice, the
public will regard you as nice,
eventually.
I would work on that rule.
Just as if your
company is worth a lot,
your share price will
reflect that eventually,
which is by the way, how
Warren Buffett made money.
It's the same principle.
There's no way, I'm afraid,
of spinning a bad thing
and making it look good.
And this has been the
mistake of the PR industry.
PR isn't about trying to
make the company look good.
It's not trying to make a rat
look like a cuddly squirrel.
PR is about communicating
the truth in effective ways.
It's not about
trying to communicate
something that isn't true.
And far too many PR's think
it is about putting lipstick
on a pig.
And I think in the
end, all you can
do is assume that your company
will have the reputation it
deserves, and make sure
the company has pitched
its behavior at a level which
will yield the reputation which
it wants.
I'm not saying
there aren't going
to be short-term bumps and
distortions, just as there
are in your share price.
But in the end, I would
work on the assumption.
Because you can
be really clever,
and you'll still
get the PR wrong.
And when you try too hard,
it'll look like it's insincere,
and it'll look like
it's insidious.
So just be-- communicating
the truth is what PR is about,
and that's it.
PETER BARRON: Yeah, I
think I agree with that.
But as you are an
economist, I just
want to ask a final
question, which
is your views on yesterday's
European commission ruling.
EVAN DAVIS: Um.
[LAUGHTER]
EVAN DAVIS: I can see both
sides of the argument.
[LAUGHTER]
EVAN DAVIS: I mean, I
think often people think--
I think the world probably
feels more competitive to you
than it might to some outsiders.
And I mean, I think there's
something in the argument.
There is quite a lot
of competition around
and quite a lot of choice.
And if there is
competition, then I
don't think it matters
so much if you're
favoring your own products.
Because we don't have to
use your search engine,
we can use someone else's.
And I think probably
to you, it feels
like there's a lot of
competition between shopping
services, potentially
between search engines,
between sites you can go to.
And so I can see why.
I can see why you might feel--
I can see why you
might feel aggrieved.
I'm not going to go further
than that, because as you know,
if you've heard anything
in the last hour that
sounds like an opinion,
you've misunderstood me.
This argument is an old one.
There's an economics
of vertical restraints,
which is about people
using their own supplies.
It's the same, by the
way, as tied pubs.
It's the same issue there, you
know, brewers who own the pub
and force the pub to take
their beer or should they have.
This issue of so-called vertical
restraints is an old issue.
And in general, I think it's
been seen as anticompetitive
by half the economics
profession who don't like
any of these vertical ties.
And the other half of
the economics profession
say as long as there's
competition for pubs,
if this pub-- if
this brewer wants
to lower the value of that
pub by insisting that it has
its rubbish beer in
it, well, they'll
make more money on the beer
than they otherwise would.
But they're making
less money on the pub.
And it doesn't matter.
So there's a sort
of huge economics
of these vertical--
these kind of privileging
the in-house business.
And the most important thing
is that there's competition
really at each side of
the deal, and that's
where I think the
argument would be.
PETER BARRON: Great.
Evan Davis, thank
you very much indeed.
EVAN DAVIS: Peter, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]